Now, this is the beginning of volume 9 and we start with March the 10th, 1909. The father
forms one single thing with Jesus. We would say the father and Jesus are one. One single
thing is just the awkward translation. Jesus gives himself continuously for souls. Okay.
So continue in my usual state. Louisa said, I found myself outside of myself with the
baby Jesus in my arms. And I said to him, tell me I'm pretty little one. What does the
father do? I think that's really funny. You know, it's obviously sitting up on his throne,
having nothing to do because he's millions of servants, you know. And he said, the father
and I are one. That's John 10 29. The father and I are one. And it's also verse 38. John
10 29 and 38. Okay. So you will find as we go along in these volumes that Jesus will
say to her over and over again, but we have to have things repeated before they actually
registers. And that right? That it was one thing to create the universe and it's quite
another matter to preserve it in creation. And so the father's working rather hard. Okay.
So Louisa said, and with the saints, what do you do? There's your image of the saints
sitting on a cloud playing the harp, you know? And he said, I give myself continuously. So
I am their life, their joy, their happiness, their immense good without end and without
boundaries. Look at the without boundaries. God is love without boundaries. We put boundaries
of race and religion and absolutely everything is love without boundaries. They are filled
with me. And they find everything in me. I am everything for them. And they are all for
me. Now that's John 1420 to 21. And it's also Galatians 220. I no longer live Christ lives
in me. Galatians 220. So on hearing this, I wanted to get hoppy, she said. And I said
to him, to the saints, you give yourself continuously. But to me then, so meagerly, so stingily,
look who she's talking to. And at intervals, to the point of having me spend part of the
day without you coming, you understood without your coming. And sometimes you hold up so
much that the fear comes to me that you may not come even until evening. She's not able
to tolerate a couple of hours without them. The rest of us have to tolerate most of our
lives. Okay. So I live dying, she said, with the most cruel and ruthless debt, death, yet
you told me that you love me very much. And he replied, my daughter, to you also, I give
myself continuously. She can't, she won't absolutely won't accept that is indwelling
her is enough. Okay. And that, of course, the divine will has to keep us preserved as
well. He said, I give myself continuously, I give myself personally, and I give myself
by grace. I give myself through light. And in many other ways, I just turned that into
English for you. Is that all right? And then who can deny that I love you very, very much?
Now at that moment, a thought came to me, Louisa said, of asking whether my state was
the will of God, and she's got to stop this. This is volume nine. And for that was more
necessary than what I was saying to him. She said, so I told him, and he instead of answering
me drew near my mouth and placed his tongue in my mouth. And I was no longer able to speak
when he found out at the end how to do it. I could just suckle something she said. But
I can tell what it was. And as he withdrew, I could only say Lord come back soon. He has
to use all kinds of methods to shut her up. So April the first very good day, isn't it?
1909. Jesus be jewels the soul with gems that come from suffering or the ring around suffering.
I don't know how many gems you've got around you. Since I was feeling very much in suffering,
Louisa said, to the point of being unable to move, I was offering my little sufferings
together with those of Jesus, which of course is what we're supposed to do all the time.
And Jesus said even the smallest item, the most smallest thing that you wouldn't even
tell somebody else. If they're offered to him, he'll make them infinite. Okay. So I was
offering them together with those of Jesus and with that intensity of love. Now she's
talking about motivation there with which he intended to glorify the Father. Now notice
she's identifying with Jesus as she unites with him. She's actually telling you what to
do, how to do it. So, and she was offering them to repair for our sins and to obtain
all those goods for which he prayed for with his sufferings. And then she said, I said to
myself, I will take it as if these sufferings were a martyrdom of mine. Of course he's
uniting them to Jesus' sufferings in his martyrdom. Okay. As if the pains were the executioners,
as if the bed was the cross. Well, I would consider the bed the cross if I was in it
for 40 years, wouldn't you? And my immobility were the ropes that kept me bound. Okay. So
as to render myself more dear and more loving to my highest good. But the executioners,
I don't see them. So who is the executioner that lacerates me and tears me to treads,
not only on the exterior of my body, but also in the most intimate parts deep in my soul
to the point that I feel at the circle of my life crack. She said, ah, my executioner
is Jesus himself. Now, in volumate, Jesus told her that love is a tyrant. It demands
everything. That's in volumate. Love is the tyrant. Now, in that little bit that we've
just read, that's Louise's first real insight into the deep privations of Jesus. She has
already heard its martyrdom. She's already heard its martyrdom of love. But she has
not actually identified all the parts with Jesus on the cross. And I call it her first
real insight. It's a fantastic moment. Okay. And so love is the tyrant, because in the
hours of the passion, you'll be told that there was the passion of love, the passion
of sins and the passion of the Jews, do you remember? And the passion of love came from
the father? And that was the worst of them of them all. Okay. So, Louise says, at that
moment, almost in a flash, Jesus told me, my daughter, too great for you is the honor
of having me as your executioner. Now, put that in English. The honor of having me as
an executioner is too great. I mean, you don't deserve it. He said, I act like a groom, a
bridegroom, who having to espouse his bride and send her out in public in order to make
her have a beautiful appearance and to make her worthy of himself, he trusts nobody, not
even espouse herself. But he himself wants to wash her, comb her, clothe her, adorn her
with gems and diamonds. Now, beside that, put Ezekiel 16 verses 1 to 4, because that is
a summary of what you find in Ezekiel 16 where God says that he found Israel, his bride in
the wilderness. She had absolutely nothing and he had to feed her and clothe her and
do absolutely everything for her. Ezekiel 16 verses 1 to 14. Okay. And I had to wash
her myself. Now, that's John 13 verses 1 to 12, Jesus washing the feet as a sign that
he had to wash his all in his blood. Is that okay? John 13, 1 to 12. And this is a great
honor for the bride, he said. More so. In other words, the Lord himself is looking after you.
More so since she will have no, she will have no such concern. In other words, you don't,
this is the exact opposite of Pelagianism, which is saving yourself. And you know, new
age is Pelagianism. And you know that you're saving yourself. Okay. So she doesn't have
to do anything. The Lord has done everything for her. Will I be pleasing to the spouse
or not? The bride doesn't have to worry about that. Will he like the way I have adorned myself
or will he reproach me as a foolish one for not having been able to guess, probably please
him most? You don't have to think about that either. It's brilliant. And he said, that's
the way it is with me with my beloved spouses. Okay. The love I have for them is so great
that I trust no one. Now, notice the priest guiding Louisa is included. I am even forced
to act as their executioner, but a loving one. Okay. And so I give her a wash or a comb
and I clot her. And you see now, why do you get the expression wash and a comb and I clother
Louisa is in a bed unable to move. So somebody has to wash and comb the hair and do everything
for her. Okay. So he says, I'm, I actually do this for your, for you interiorly. And
I be jewel her. Okay. But not with the gems that come from earth, which are things that
are superficial, rather with the gems that I make come out from the depth of her soul.
From the most intimate parts, which are formed at the touch of my fingers. Now, Sam eight
verse three says he created the universe with the tip of his fingers that creates suffering.
Now, the reason why I said that Sam eight says that with the tip of his fingers or the touch
of his fingers that he actually created the universe. Here he's saying that with the touch
of his fingers, he's able to create suffering. I see you see in the last couple of volumes,
we've noticed that Louisa says she has no external sufferings and yet she's she's suffering
terribly inside. He's saying, I'm able to create it for you. This is spiritual and gradually
she will come to realize that she's been crucified within only slowly. And that's why that inside
at the beginning of this message is actually terribly important. Okay. So, so at the touch
of my fingers that creates suffering and from suffering come the gems. And the gems convert
into gold convert the will sorry into gold. And this will converted into gold by my own
hands will send out all kinds of things. The most beautiful crowns, the most magnificent
garments, the most fragrant flowers, the most pleasing, pleasant melodies. And with my own
hands as I produce them, I keep arranging them to adorn her more and more. And all this happens
with suffering souls that that means that you're talking mostly about victim souls. Okay.
So am I not right in telling you too great is the honor for you. So I have to give you
Ephesians 210. Ephesians 210. We are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus. I have
to give you Philippians one six that the Lord finishes a job that he starts unless you stop
him. And I have to give you a Deuteronomy 32, 12. The Lord alone was her guide. Okay.
In other words, you're getting back the scriptures just given to you in a personal experience.
It's really fantastic. So May the 5th, 1909, sufferings impress the sanctity of Jesus in
the soul. There's all kinds of sanctities, but there's only one sanctity of Jesus.
As I was in my usual state, my good Jesus made himself heard just a little telling me
with his sweet word, my daughter, mortifications, miseries, privations, sufferings, crosses.
For those who will make use of them, they serve for nothing but to impress my own sanctity
in the soul. And if she kept embellishing herself with all kinds, as if she had kept
embellishing herself with all varieties of divine colors, even more, there are nothing
other than many fragrances of heaven with which the soul remains all perfumed. You have a
good description there of the difference between Catholic theology and Protestant theology.
If you've been involved in charismatic renewal, particularly if you've been very deeply in
it, you probably didn't know that you were being influenced by an evangelical Protestant
theology, which says, Jesus did it all. You don't have to do anything. There's no sufferings.
Thank you very much. No cross. That was for him. You get healed of everything. You get
all the gifts. You get powerful. You become great. He paid. You get the benefits. That's
totally the opposite of what you've just read here, where Jesus asks us to participate in
the cross, to be part of him in redeeming the world. And he gets you to look away from
your own body, and to look away even from your own salvation is very difficult to get people
to look away from that, and to look through his eyes at the whole of humanity past, present
and future, and participate with him in their redemption so that you can be part of his
triumph. It's a totally different theology. Yeah. And you just need to clarify that because
people coming in from prayer groups into divine will actually have a big problem because they
don't know they haven't worked out the influences that have been upon them. Now they're not faulty.
It's not their fault or anything. These are the influences that were upon them. It's taken
me a good long time to work it out as well. So that's why some people can't take the divine
will teachings at all, because they don't want the the mortifications and the self denial
and the carrying of the cross and suffering and redeeming suffering. They don't want
that at all. Forget about it. I've got to get healed of everything. I've got to walk
on cushions to heaven. And I've got to be the powerful one. So I've met people in prayer
groups. I'm not saying there's anything wrong with a prayer group, but I've met people in
prayer groups who are fighting each other over. And you know, I have this gift and you have
that gift and the other gift. That's the exact opposite of this. Okay, we can talk about
it later if you want. So the next one is May the 8th, 1909. This I have a VIP on this one.
Look at the heading. One who talks much is empty of God. Wow, it's not fantastic. So
to prove what I need to give you, put it beside the heading literally. Proverbs 10, 19. It's
all about talk. Proverbs 10, 19. And 12, 18, Proverbs. And 13, 3. Now, I only gave you
3. There are 50. Proverbs 13, 3 says, "There's life and death in the power of the tongue
and the person who uses it must eat the fruit thereof. I could kill somebody with my tongue.
I might kill them with a knife, but I can do it with my tongue very easily." Okay. So
to give you Titus 1, 10. Thank God this message isn't too long, isn't it great? So continue
in my usual state, Louisa said, "My beloved Jesus made himself seen for just a little
and he told me. My daughter, one who talks much shows that he, she or it." And notice
that I have a third gender. It is empty in the interior. Now, right from the very beginning
of the church, men and women have taken vows of silence to try and give God a chance and
to hear God. So they've gone out into the deserts. Look at our wonderful testimony and
Schkeling Michael where they went literally on a rock so that they could hear God. While
one who was filled with God, finding more, that my book says taste, changed that to satisfaction.
Finding more satisfaction in his interior does not want to lose this satisfaction, so
he hardly speaks and only out of necessity. Now, you will find that with people who grow
closer and closer to God. They've less and less to say and they certainly don't have
small talk. And even while speaking, he never departs from his interior. That's the big
bit. You need to put a VIP beside that one. In other words, you never lose the connection
with the Lord. And he tries as much as he can to impress on others that which he feels
within himself. Now, they'd hang even the first tree nowadays for doing that. On the
other hand, one who talks much is not only empty of God, but with his much talking he
tries to empty others of God as well. Isn't that something? Wow. So I want to give you
Amos 513 and don't blame me. He was 513. Read it yourself. Okay. So May the 16th, 1909.
The sun is a symbol of grace. Now, in these writings, the sun is a symbol of Jesus himself,
who is the sun of justice, you know? It's also a symbol of grace. But you may not remember
back in Volume 3, Jesus said, I am grace. Okay, I am grace. So continue in my usual state.
Blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me. My daughter, the sun is, we would
say, a symbol of grace. When it finds a void, be it even a cave, a vault, a fissure, a hall,
as long as there is empty space and a little opening through which to penetrate, the sun
enters and fills everything with light. In other words, give any kind of room and the
light will find it. So, and if it's light does not penetrate more, it's not because
it lacks light, but rather because of the lack of space in which to be able to diffuse
its light more. This is terribly important. It is the same with my grace, he said. It
is more than a majestic sun. It envelops all creatures with its beneficial influence. However,
it does not enter but into empty hearts. That's why we've been told from volumes 1 to 4 that
we've to empty ourselves of self and selfishness and sin to make room for grace to come in.
And if grace can't get in, it means something is in there that is contrary to grace. But
it will only go into empty hearts. As much space as it finds, so much light does it let
penetrate into the heart. This is why you got so much teaching on detachment in volumes
1 to 4. Now, the heart represents the real you, your inner self. It isn't just a valentine
symbol of romantic love. That's not the way it is in the scripture. So, heart is used
in the same way here as in the scriptures means the real you inside, your persona. So,
these voids, spaces that you make for grace to come in, what are they? How are they formed?
Number one, humility is the whole which digs and forms, we would say, the whole or whatever.
Number two, detachment from everything and also from oneself is the void itself. Now,
notice, the big thing about detachment is detachment from yourself. A person may, a person can
appear to you religious and even holy. And the book of Proverbs says, "Never judge a
man before he opens his mouth." And then you have a conversation with this holy person
and they dig their heels in and they hold tenaciously to their own opinion. Whether they're right
or wrong, they're holding tenaciously to their own opinion, blah, blah, blah. That means
self has a big S. Because if you're humble, you'd listen to somebody else's and you wouldn't
impose your own. And just giving you that as a very simple way to make a little test.
Is that okay? Very simple way. So, detachment from oneself is actually more important than
detachment from everything else. And to be detached from yourself, it's your own interest,
your own opinion, your own this, your own that, your own value. All the things they tell you
nowadays to sell yourself on, which we detach detached from. The window in order to let the
light come into the void is trust in God. There's the third one. And you start with humility
and the second one is detachment and the third one is trust in God. And trust in God and distrust
of ourselves. Now distrust of ourselves is not this false thing that I have found all
over the place in Ireland. Asher, I can't do that. You know what I mean? And they have
a degree in music and they won't play a piano for you. You know what I mean? I mean, that's
just ludicrous. That's false humility. Real humility. If you're able to play a piano,
you'll play it and give everybody the joy of it. Do you know what I mean? That's real
humility. You give it. The distrust of yourself is that you, sorry, the distrust of yourself
is that you are not trying to save yourself, that you are relying on the Lord's grace to
bring it through on everything. Is that okay? Therefore, as much trust as one has, so much
does he enlarge the door in order to let the light in and to take more grace? Now, Saint
Therese said, you will receive from God as much as you have confidence or trust in him.
So the fourth one is the custodian that keeps the light and expands it is peace. So this
are four things. Humility, detachment, trust and peace. That's a nice clear little message
for you. So May the 20th, 1909, we come back to the subject of love, which I've told you
many times that the summary of these 36 volumes is divine will and love. They're the two main
themes. Okay? So the love for God surpasses everything else. So Louisa says, continuing
in my usual state, Jesus just barely made himself seen in a flash of light. Why? Because
God is light one John one five. Do you want to put it in there? Flash of light. One John
one five. And he told me my daughter, there's nothing that can surpass love. So beside that,
I want you to put one Corinthians 14 one at the side. One Corinthians 14 one, you must
want love more than anything else. Okay? Neither doctrine nor dignity and much less nobility.
At the most, one who uses those for the good of making speculations around my being can
know me more or less. Now he's talking about the theologians and these people who talk
more than anything else. He says they get to know you a little bit. But one who reaches
the point of making me his own object, that is love. The only one who really gets to know
God is the one who reaches out to him personally to his heart, which is love. So that's one
Corinthians 13 one to 13. Now who reaches the point of eating me as one does with food?
That's love. How can you eat him in the Eucharist? You also eat his word. One who loves me devours
me. Well, Louisa certainly does. And one who loves me finds my being identified with each
particle of his being. Now there's the union with God is not just some ethereal mystical
thing up in the ether, but literally every part of your being is identified with him.
There is as much difference between one who really loves me and you need to add the word
all the others. Whatever their conditions or qualities may be as between one who knows
a precious object appreciates it, steams it, but it doesn't belong to him. So they're
the scholars who can talk about it backwards and frontwards. And one who possesses that
object because it's his own. So when Saint Berndette of Lords was brought in from the
fields at the age of 11 to receive Holy Communion, she was asked, who is God? And she said God
is love. And the nun told her it was the wrong answer. That wasn't the answer in the book.
But she was correct. It's one John 4, 7 to 17. God is love. And so Bernadette came in
with the knowledge that was in her soul that she had loved God all this time. Can the rest
of you turn off your mobile? Who is more fortunate than these, Jesus says? The one who knows about
it or the one who possesses it? Certainly the one who possesses it. That's like saying,
who is the most unfortunate? The one looking at the television at somebody else having
won the lottery. Turn it off. Is it the person looking at the television with somebody else
having celebrating winning the lottery or actually winning it yourself? That's what he's saying.
One possesses it and the other doesn't. So love makes... Watch this now. This is terribly
important. Love makes up for doctrine and surpasses it. Now, that's the example I've
already given to you about Saint Bernadette. She didn't have the words that the nun had
in the nun's book, which she had the knowledge in her heart. It makes up for dignity and surpasses
all dignities. That is, if I, as an absolute nobody in the church, love God to the end
of this degree and you have a cardinal who doesn't, then the cardinal misses out. So it
makes up for the dignity. Providing one with divine dignity. That's why we declare some
people saints. The dignity they have acquired is divine. So love makes up for everything
and surpasses everything. Love is it. Why is love it because God is love? And God is love
one John for seven to 17. Okay. Now, you see, there are people in the church who will tell
you, getting your degree in theology is more important than anything else. And the Lord
says, No, no, it's your degree in love. So made the 22nd, 1909, we're at love again. Okay.
And I want to give you Ephesians three versus 14 to 21. That is, you must be grounded in
love, built on love, and reach the fullness of love. So this morning, Louisa said, I received
communion. Blessed Jesus did not come. And after waiting for a long time between vigil
and sleep, in seeing that time was passing and Jesus was not coming, I wanted to go out
of my sleep. But at the same time, I wanted to stay because of the torment I felt in my
heart and not seeing it. Now this sleep is not sleep in bed. This is the very deep state
of a person in prayer, but they're not actually in ecstasy. Is that okay? It's the very deep
state of prayer. It looks like sleep to somebody outside of it. And it's very often called
sleep as well was not actually sleep. I felt like a baby who wanting to sleep and being
wakened by four starts making fusses and cries. However, in my fussing while striving to wake
up, I said in my interior, what a bitter separation. She's not asleep. Is she? I feel lifeless
and yet I live, but this is harder than death. However, may your privation be for love of
you? Now you see, she's getting the message. Okay. For love of you, the bitterness I feel
for love of you, my tormented heart, for love of you, the life I don't feel though I live.
But so that it may be more acceptable to you. I unite this suffering of mine to the intensity
of your love. And with mine, I offer you your own love. Now, first of all, she offers the
pains that she names out of love for him. And then she says, no, I want to go further.
I want to unite it with your love so that my acts of love are divine. Isn't that fantastic?
Now, she's at long last discovered what to do with her privations. She wasn't exactly
asleep, was she? But as I was saying this, Jesus moved in my interior and he told me
how sweet and delightful in my hearing is the note of love. Why everything is about love.
And Matthew 22, when you remember this second. And I can't remember the verses right now
where Jesus says that the whole law and the prophets hang on the law of love, the whole
law. And when he says, hang on that, they, they, they rabbis when they were discussing
things together, they would say, I put such and such a point hangs on such and such a
text and such and such a thing hang. And Jesus said, the whole of scripture hangs on love
God and love your neighbor. He said that this is it, this is the essence, it's the center
of everything. I think it's verses 22 to 24. I think so. And if I'm wrong, you can correct
it in your own book. Yeah, who, oh, sorry. He said, he loves to hear the note of love.
Say it again. He said, repeat it again, cheer my hearing with these notes of love. Now any
human lover would say the same thing to their beloved, wouldn't they say it again? Even
a child will say it again. And a mother will say it to a child, say it again. Because there's
nothing more beautiful than to hear someone speaking to you of love. And he says that
it's so harmonious, which to send deep into my heart and sweeten all of me. Because what
the Lord has loved us infinitely, and he's looking for love in return. Now God's infinite
love is Jeremiah 31, 31, 3. Jeremiah 31, 3. I've loved you with the never lasting love.
And I am constant. Yeah. Three. So who would believe it? I'm ashamed to say it, Louisa
said. In my hoppiness, I answered. I don't want to say it. Can you imagine? I try and
imagine the level that this woman is at. That's what gets me every time. You get sweetened
and I get more embittered. You wouldn't think she was talking to a divine person, would you?
My sweet Jesus kept silent. Watch this now. As though being displeased with my answer,
will you should be. And as soon as I woke up, I repeated my notes of love many times. However,
he did not let himself be heard or seen for the whole day. Guess who was displeased? And
he's well even to short. Okay. So made the 25th, 1909, God's love for us. You often find
a whole group of texts dealing with the same subject. So heading here is Jesus confounds
the soul with love. Continuing in my usual state, blessed Jesus was not coming. However,
for the whole day, I felt as if there was somebody over me. He's there. He keeps telling
her he's with her all the time. Who would not let me waste one minute of time, but would
keep me always in continuous prayer. A thought wanted to distract me by saying to me when
the Lord doesn't come, you pray more, you're more attentive. And by this, you yourself give
him the field not to come because the Lord would say, since she behaves better when I
don't go, it's better than me not to come. Since I would not waste time in listening
to what my thought was saying, she obviously listened enough for it to be able to tell
us. In order to shut the door on its face, I said, the more he doesn't come, the more
I will confound him with love. Now lovers do say things that are in excess. I will confound
him with love. Imagine confounding love itself. I don't want to give him the occasion. This
is what I can do. And this is what I want to do. And he is free to do whatever he wants.
Talk about someone being huffy. And without thinking of the nonsense that my thought
had told me, I continue to do what I was supposed to do. In the evening, however, I didn't even
remember about this. Blessed Jesus came, almost smiling at me, and he told me, "Bravo, bravo!"
My lover, he said, who wants to confound me with love. However, I tell you, you will never
confound me. Why? She's a creature and he's the creator. And if sometimes it seems that
I am confounded with love, it is I who give you the freedom to do it. John 15, 5, without
me, you can do nothing. Because the only relief and the thing that I most enjoy from creatures
is love. In fact, it was I who solicited you to pray, who prayed with you, who gave
you no respite. She suspected it was him, of course. So, instead of me being confounded,
I confounded you with love. And since you felt all filled with love and work confounded by
it, in seeing that my love was pouring so much into you, you thought that you were confounding
me with love. Talk about getting it upside down. However, I tell you, as long as you
try to love me more, I delight in these mistakes if yours, and I make them a little game between
you and me. Not a joke. He never jokes. Okay. So, July the 14, 1909 is about peace. Another
major topic because love, joy and peace, do you remember? So, Philippians 4, 7, the peace
that passes all understanding. Philippians 4, 7. I've gone through almost bitter time
because of the privation of blessed Jesus, Louisa said. At most, he would make himself
seen like shadow and lightning, and sometimes even the lightning would seem to be running
away. My mind was troubled by this thought, how cruelly he has left me, Jesus, who is
so good. Maybe it wasn't him who used to come. His goodness would not have done this to me.
Who knows whether it was the devil or my fantasy or dreams. But in my inmost soul, I did not
want to hear this naturally enough because it wasn't right. It wanted to remain at peace,
and this is very important. She's showing you that if you're getting disturbed thoughts
on the outside, that you just go away from them and go into your interior. Now, Louisa
isn't the first holy person to tell us that all the saints have told us, that even if
you're in prayer and you're being distracted by a thought, just simply neglected and get
on in more interior with your prayer. And let the thought come and go without giving
it any attention. And then Satan can't use it to really get you. That's what she's saying.
I didn't want to hear this. I wanted to stay at peace. So, it didn't want to be annoyed
with anything. It would penetrate more and more into the will of God. You see, you go
deeper and deeper, okay? My soul would hide in the divine will. That's the it. Falling
into a profound sleep. You see, now that sleep is not sleep as you know it. It's deep contemplation.
Okay? It's a contemplative state. And there's no way to wake up. But the language for that
sleep is Sam 131. My soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap. And it seems that
good Jesus encloses it so much in his will that he does not allow one to find even the
door in order to knock and to let it hear that Jesus has left it. And so it sleeps and it
remains in peace. Sam 127 verse two as well. Sam 127 verse two. Receiving no answer, the
mind says to itself, am I the only one to take this this bile? Look at this. I too want
to become calm and to do the will of God. Whatever comes, let it come. And as long as
I do the will of God. So what she's saying is, no matter what comes, I'm going to stay
only doing the will of God. There's the choice that keeps you out of all trouble and keeps
Satan at bay because he cannot touch someone who chooses to do the will of God. Now this
morning, as I was thinking of what I'd said above, good Jesus told me, my daughter, if
these were fantasies, what's going on between her and him, dreams, demons, they would not
have so much strength as to make you possess the halo of peace. One Corinthians 14 33.
In other words, anything coming from the demon cannot have the fruit of peace. That's the
number one. Okay. And not just for one day, but for 25 years, she's now in the bed, a
quarter of a century. No one could have made that aura of sweet peace breeze inside and
outside of you. Only the one who is all peace. Romans 1533. Romans 1533. Ephesians 24.
Okay. So only the one who is all peace. And if a breath of disturbance could surprise
him, he would cease to be God. His majesty would be obfuscated. His greatness, which
shrink his power would be weakened. In some, the whole of the divine being would receive
a shake. But the one who possesses you, whom you possess. One Thessalonians 523. The one
whom you who possesses you and whom you possess is over you. He watches over you continuously
for any breath of disturbance. Okay. I also want to give you a song of songs to four.
Remember that in all of my comings, I have always corrected you if there was a breath
of disturbance in you. Now you get that very specifically from volumes one to four. Just
put V one to four beside that because that's where he was training her to stay in peace
no matter what happened. One to four. So remember that in all of my comings, I have
always corrected you if there was a breath of disturbance in you. And nothing would
displease me more than not seeing you in perfect peace. Isaiah 26 3. It is the Lord
who keeps us in perfect peace. And only then would I disappear from you when I would see
you all peaceful again. Fantasy and dreams and much less the devil do not have this power.
My books as virtue. And even less could they give it to others. Therefore, calm yourself
and do not be ungrateful. Okay. So July the 24th, 1909, still we're talking about love.
Everything the soul does out of love for God enters into him and is transformed into his
own works. That's why it's so essential to do absolutely everything no matter how small
no matter how trivial to do it for love of him. And if you're not going to remember it,
just make the intention and say, Lord, I make the intention that every single thing I do
this day is out of love for you. Whether I forget it or not, that's my intention. And
so you set your compass. So I was thinking of the misery of my present state. And I said
to myself how everything is over for me, how good Jesus has forgotten about everything.
She loves that. He no longer remembers my hardships, the sufferings I've gone through
for and all these years in bed. And so my mind kept going back to some specialities
of suffering and the gravest ones which I've gone through. At that moment, blessed Jesus
told me, my daughter, everything and you really need to ring that one. Everything that is
done for love of me enters into me becomes part of him and is transformed into my own
works. And since my works are for the good of all, you see, that's one of the absolute
things about divine will. It's for everybody. It's universal. That is for the pilgrim souls,
the purging souls and the triumphant souls. Everything you have done and suffered from
me is present in me because everything in the divine will is present. Isn't that right?
It does its office for the good of all, just as my works do. Would you rather take them
back within yourself? Notice, he says, seems to think that that's possible. That's right
me? Louisa answered me, it'd never be Lord, she said. But in spite of this, I continue
to think about it being a little distracted from my usual interior work and good Jesus
repeated, you don't want to stop it. I'm going to make you stop it. And he placed himself
in my interior, praying in a loud voice, saying, all that I was supposed to say. And on seeing
this, I remain confused and I followed good Jesus. And when he saw that I was no longer
paying attention to anything else, then he kept silent and I remained alone doing what
I was supposed to do. Now, there's several things going on there. One is, he expects
that when he has answered something, she'll drop it. But sometimes we don't drop it. We're
like the dog going back to the bone, aren't we? And he says to it, you must have this
control, stop it. And since she couldn't do it, he said, I'm going to make you do it.
And since he is present in her interior in a way that is totally outstanding, because
he's by located himself in her interior, he started praying loudly in her interior what
she was supposed to be doing, until she got the message. And then when she started doing
what she should have been doing, he stopped. Look who steps in. Do you remember the story
of the footprints? He's carrying you and he's doing it when you're not able to do it. And
you have an extraordinary example of the humility of God there. Okay. So July the 27th, 1909,
we're talking about total surrender to the divine will. This is where we're going. And
the heading that's given to you mightn't help. And that is, the soul is the toy of Jesus.
Well, if he's a child and he's playing with the toy. Okay. As I was in my usual state,
I thought to myself, what am I here for? I'm no longer good for anything. He does not
come. And I have remained as a useless object. Because without him, I am worth nothing. That's
your John 15 five. That's a literal quotation there. I suffer nothing. So why keep me on
the earth any longer? And he just flashing by told me, my daughter, I keep you for fun.
And toys are not always kept in one's hands. Many times they are not touched even for months
and months. But in spite of this, when the owner of that toy wants it, one does not cease
to form, it does not cease to form his enjoyment, not amusement enjoyment. Do you perhaps want
me to have not even one toy on the earth? Let me enjoy myself. Knock out the amuse again.
Let me enjoy myself with you on earth as I please. And in exchange, I will let you enjoy
yourself with me forever. That's not about exchanges. Now, if you remember the writings
of Saint Therese of Lissue, she compared herself to a little ball that the child Jesus would
play with and that he could kick into a corner and forget about it. And he could even neglect
it and everything. You know what I mean? She had an extraordinary understanding of this.
It's just an image, of course, being the play thing. It is that you're totally surrendered.
That's why I gave you the heading, totally surrendered to the Lord and that he can carry
out his will in you, unhindered. That's why I gave you my own heading there, which I think
says it better. So July the 29th, 1909, we're back to peace again. Notice all these central
themes coming back. Peace is divine virtue. So continue in my usual state, I said to myself,
why does the Lord absolutely want no breath of disturbance, volumes one to four, enter
into me and that in all things I remain at peace? It seems that nothing pleases him. Watch
this now. But that even great works, heroic virtues, atrocious sufferings, it seems that
he snips in the soul. I think it's fascinating the way she reacts to him, you know. He snips
around and with all those things, if she has no peace, he remains nauseated and displeased
with the soul. At that moment, it's funny, isn't it? He made himself heard and with dignified
and imposing voice. He doesn't like being told. He snips around. Does he? He answered
my why now, my friends, when we get to volume 14, he has a whole section on why? And he says,
the why in adults comes from hell. Yeah. The why of a child doesn't because when a child
is opening up, they've got to find out why is that called a cop and why is that called
a plate and all the rest of it. All their why is are fine. He says, the why of the adult
is wrong. In other words, we're questioning God. We question his will. He question his
ways. We question his scriptures. He we question his grace. We question, we question, we question,
we question, we question. And he said, you should surrender instead. So that's why he's
coming to her in an imposing way. He doesn't like the why. Peace, he said, is a divine virtue.
Now the other virtues are human. Now this is a pronouncement rather than just a teaching.
So any virtue, if it is not crowned with peace cannot be called virtue, but vice is not amazing.
This is why I cherish peace so much because peace is the surest sign underline that one
suffers and works for me. And it is the heritage that I give to my children. You see, that's
a pronouncement. I give it to my children. It is of the eternal peace that they will
enjoy in heaven. So I have to give you a whole lot of stuff here. Luke 1, 79, Luke 1, 79,
and 214. Jesus is the prince of peace. And there's peace to anybody of goodwill in 214.
Peace, I give you, not as the world gives peace. John 1633 and John 20, 19 to 20. And
there's lots more old and New Testament. So August the 2nd, 1909, the soul is a toy made
of gold and diamonds. So we're going back to the toy subject. I was thinking about
I wrote on the 27th of last month, you said, and I said to myself, I thought I was something
in the hands of the Lord, I'm only a toy. I love this. The problem here is nothingness.
I thought I was something. Now I discover I'm only a toy. That's terribly important.
I remember asking a group of teenagers in Africa, Oh, back in the 1960s, what did they
want to become? And they wanted to become all kinds of things with one little girl stood
up and she was in the back of the class. She said, I want to be a very important somebody.
I said, you're the only one who told the truth. I said, everybody wants to be a very
important somebody to somebody. It's husband, to wife, parent, to child, friend, to friend.
Do you know what I mean? But I want to be a very important somebody by itself is wrong.
Boy, another I want to be the exalted one, but God actually called us to be a very important
somebody to somebody, whether that somebody is singular or plural. So here she's playing
with this thing and these messages are for us. They're not really for her. I'm nothing
but a toy. What a most wretched object I am. Now the Lord's putting this in here in case
anybody had theological problems with the last one. So toys can be made of clay, earth,
turf, labby, elastic band. They had elastic band in 1909. It's not interesting. Such that
it's sufficient that they fall on the ground or just the slightest inconvenience and they
break. They didn't have plastic, you see, and no longer being useful for the game, they're
thrown away. Oh my good, how oppressed I feel at the thought that one day or another you'll
throw me away. And good Jesus made himself heard and told me, my daughter do not oppress
yourself. When toys are made of wretched matter, they break and one throws them away. But when
they're made of gold or diamonds, they told her that in the last one as well. Or of any
precious material, one has them fixed and they always serve to form the enjoyment of
the one who has the good of possessing them. So you are for me. Now what does he mean by
golden diamond? You are precious in my eyes. Okay, that's what he's saying. Now let me know
that I've used to the words you are precious. I would write them down. You're precious in
my eyes and I love you. That's Isaiah 43. The text had to come to me first. I can't remember
the verse at the moment, but that's the text. You're precious in my eyes and I love you.
So golden diamonds is precious. Okay. So a toy made of diamonds and a purest gold because
you have my image in you. That's Genesis 2, 2, 7 and it's Romans 8, 29, Genesis 2, 7
and Romans 8, 29. You have my image in you and because I paid the price of my blood to
purchase you. Now look at the gold and the diamonds. They're the image of God and the
precious blood that redeemed us. Notice the preciousness is not in ourselves. So what
do you think she's being talked about here? Her nothingness. Isn't that it? So it's the
precious blood that purchase you and you are adorned with the likeness of my sufferings.
Therefore you are not a wretched object that I would throw away. Rather it costs me very
much. You can be tranquil. There's no danger I'll throw you away. Okay. So October the
first 1909. Watch this one now. Jesus counts ways and measures everything in the soul.
I don't know if your reaction to that is, but mine is out. Okay. Do not everything measure.
Do you? Some things. Okay. Being very afflicted because of my poor state, Louisa said, I
felt nauseating to myself. I think that's the most wonderful confession. Have you ever
been nauseating to yourself? It's terribly important that if you go through a space in
which you're so out of sorts and out of culture with everything, it's actually the height
of charity to tell whoever you live with and work with, just keep a space between me and
you. I'm not civil. Don't talk to me until I come around. It's actually terribly important.
I don't know have you ever even said to the Lord in a time of crisis I have. When you
be going through a crisis inside, I say, Lord, just hold on to me until I come around. And
the images of a mother holding a child in a tantrum and you just hold the child and
if you have any wisdom, you'll say nothing. Just hold the child and give the child the
strength of your body and the strength of your love and the child will eventually calm
down and later on, then you can have a discussion. But if you take on the tantrum, you're going
to have no discussion, isn't that right? Okay. So that's, that's us being nauseating to ourselves.
And it is an experience that we do have. And she said, I must be abominable before God.
I felt as if the Lord had left me halfway on the path and without him, I feel I cannot
go any further. I feel he no longer wants to use me in order to spare the world the chastisement.
This is very, very important. She's having a shift in her vocation. And there's nobody
to tell her what's going on. The priest has got to wait until messages come from the Lord.
He doesn't know what's going on. It's only then he knows. So she's from from we're in
volume nine. So in volume nine, she begins to shift away from being the victim soul taking
the crown of thorns and crucifixion and all the rest to this interior suffering that she's
been talking about in the last few messages. And she is going to be used as the key to
open the kingdom of the divine will for everybody else. Now that vocation is unknown in the church.
So the priest can't help her. She doesn't know what's going on. And so she actually
suffers greatly in the turnaround. Okay. And we need this because once you get into volume
11, then she's on the high road of the divine will. So here she's saying, I notice he's
not using me to stop the despair of the chastisements. That means that the victim soul bit is being
drawn back. And so he has moved crosses and thorns away from me. He has discontinued all
my sharing in the passion and the communications. The only thing I see is that he's on the alert
that I remain in peace. That's the important bit that she must stay in peace while this
transformation is happening. It's very hard on her because she doesn't know where it's
going. And we don't like things happening to us that we don't know where it's going,
do we? My God, what pain she said. If you yourself did not keep me distracted by these
losses and crosses of you, that's that that's the deprivations. And of everything, I would
die of grief, she said. If it wasn't for your holy will into what a sea of troubles I would
have fallen. Oh, keep me always in your holy will. This is enough for me. And it isn't
you know, because she'll be back complaining again. Now, as I was in my usual state, I
was crying and saying to myself, good Jesus has taken me into no account. And she said,
she said, it's enough. And she goes on complaining. You know what I mean? He has taken me into
no account of the years of bed or of the sacrifices, nothing. Otherwise, he would not have left
me and I cried and I cried the song of songs, three versus one to two, song of songs, SS,
three versus one to that's the, the bride has lost the bridegroom and she goes frantic.
Okay, three versus one to two. So at that moment, I felt a move in my interior and I lost consciousness
that means she went into ecstasy and also outside of myself into an out-of-the-body condition.
And I kept crying. Then as if a door had opened in my interior, I saw Jesus. I felt hoppy
and I didn't say anything to him. I just kept crying and he told me, Cam yourself, Cam
yourself stop crying. Do not cry. I feel my heart touched and I faint with love for you.
Now, I faint with love for you is song of songs two, five, song of songs two, five and
also song of songs five, eight. Do you want to increase my pains because of your love?
Then assuming a majestic air as though sitting on a throne within my heart, he seemed to
hold a pen in his hand and to write. And that's not usually a picture we have of Jesus. And
turning to me, he said, see whether I do not take things into account. What's the writing?
It's the books of heaven. Do you remember that everything's written in the books? Not
only the years in bed, the sacrifices, but even the thoughts you have for me. I am writing
your affections, your desires, everything, everything, even that which you will suffer.
So let me give you two, before you move on, two references for the Lamb's book of life.
Okay, because it's the book of life is written writing in its revelation at 2012, Revelation
2012 and 21, 27, the Lamb's book of life, everything is written in it. So he said, everything that
which you want to do or suffer, but you don't because I don't concede it to you. Now notice,
she's saying to her, she wants to suffer to relieve humanity of chastisements and he takes
it as if it was done. Now, we had that in a huge way in the life of Saint Therese of
Lesus. She wanted to be a priest, she wanted to be a missionary, she wanted to be a teacher,
she wanted to be this and that and the other and the Lord said, Don, what does he say in
divine will you desire it? I do it. Okay. So when we truly want to do something, but we
are not in the position of being able to do it. And we say to that, I would love to
help those poor people in Uganda, but there's no possibility at all of me going there. I
would love to do it. He takes it as done. It's fantastic. Yeah, it's really beautiful.
So I count way and measure everything so that nothing may be lost and you may be repaid
for everything. And as I write, I keep it in my own heart. Okay. Do you remember Peter,
the Apostle saying to Jesus, the mother, we're going to get, we left everything. And then
Jesus told him that you will get a hundred percent of houses. I don't know if you want
to hundred houses for one. A hundred, a hundred percent of fathers. No, one was enough. A hundred
percent of mothers. No, one was enough for me anyway. A hundred percent of brothers. No,
one was enough. Definitely. A hundred percent of sisters. No, I've got seven. That's enough.
What was he saying? I know that the strange thing is he was talking to Jewish people and
the last thing on the planet, a Jewish man, wanted was a hundred percent of sisters. Why?
Because they had the same job then as the Muslim men have now that you have to keep the
girls pure and holy until they're married and you have to, you have to ensure that they
are a virgin on the day that they're wedding. They did want to hundred them. So what was
he saying? Isn't it fascinating? He was using all that imagery and when you just look at
who needs a hundred houses, you don't. All that elaborate imagery was just simply saying
you have no idea of the reward that God has for you in heaven even for the smallest thing
you've given up. And Paul says that in Romans 8. Now, Romans 8. Now, I've only just talked
of it this minute so I haven't got the verse. He says that the sufferings in this life are
nothing compared to the glory that is prepared for us. Okay. So, Louisa then says, I don't
know, but I found myself inside of Jesus. A while before I was in my interior. It seemed
that the head of Jesus was in place of my head and all of my members served as his body.
Making see the full identification there. That's Galatians 2.20. I no longer live. Christ
lives in me. And he repeated, see how I keep you like the members of my own body and then
he disappeared. After a little while, as I continued to be afflicted, bursting into crying
every now and then, Jesus came back and told me, my daughter, courage, I have not left
you. That's Joshua 1.5. I will not leave you. Joshua 1.5. And John 14.18. John 14.18 where
Jesus said, I will not leave you orphans. Okay. I've not left you. Rather, I am hidden
because if I let myself be seen as before, you would bind me everywhere. And I would
not be able to chastise the world in anything who has been telling her that for nine volumes,
hasn't he? And I would not be able to chastise. Okay. Nor have I left you halfway on the path.
Don't you remember that these last, what these last years of your life are? These are years
wanted by your confessor. He asked for them. Okay. Don't you remember that not once, but
as many as four or five times you found yourself fighting with me. I wanted to take you with
me that is in death. Okay. And you would tell me that obedience didn't want it. And while
I had prepared you in order to take you with me, I was forced to leave you on earth again.
Look now at the consequences you are bearing. Is that interesting? These are years of pause
and patience. Isaiah 40 31. Those who wait on the Lord shall renew their strength. They
shall mount up with wings like the eagle. They shall run and not be weary. They shall walk
and not faint. Okay. 40 40 31. So these are years of pause and of patience. Charity and
obedience have their own thorns. In other words, their own price, which open large wounds
and make the heart bleed. But they make the most ruby red fragrant and beautiful roses
bloom. Now, we all know that the blood red rose represents the Lord in his passion.
In fact, in seeing in your confessor the fruit of his goodwill and his charity and the fear
that the world might be chastised because of this, I somehow concurred with him. But
if I had not found anybody who would pray me and interpose himself, you would certainly
not be here. He says you're alive because the confessor says it, but you remember back
in volumes three and four that you got an obedience not to die. Do you remember that?
But come courage, the exile will not be too long after all, the poor girl. She doesn't
die until she's in her 80s. And I promise you that the day will come when I will not
let myself be overcome by anyone. She died during the night, didn't she? And they didn't
even know she was dead the following day. They just thought she was an ecstasy. So she
got plenty of chance to get out if I can put it that way.
Louisa said, who can tell what bitterness in what bitterness I swim comforted just but
embittered down to the marrow of my bones. I cannot remember this without crying so much
so that in telling it to the confessor, the heat of my tears was such that it seemed
I would get upset with him. Why would you get upset at him because the Lord blamed him?
It's all your fault. Okay. And I truly said to him, you've been the cause of my troubles.
Now, if that's all she said, it was very mild. Okay. I'm going to stop there now because
we're going to a different subject and the time is up.